I'm the jury please listen to your
verdict as it has been accepted and
recorded they have been through so much
the emotions of this moment clear in the
courtroom the man who publicly denied
their children were slaughtered in their
classroom who called them actors and
Unleashed his followers to harass them
with death threats that man Alex Jones
will pay for what he did defamation
slander damages past the future 25
million dollars
be emotional distress damages past and
future 32 million six hundred thousand
dollars Jones is already facing one
judgment for 45 million dollars for this
conduct but this was by far the biggest
penalty
965 million dollars to the families of
eight students and staff that were
killed in their Sandy Hook classroom and
an FBI agent who was also targeted by
Jones all I can really say is that I'm
just proud that
what we are able to accomplish was just
to Simply tell the truth and it
shouldn't be this hard and it shouldn't
be this scary during the trial Jones
didn't help his case telling the
families he's done apologizing something
he defended outside of Court I've
apologized for past things I said to her
people's feelings but I wasn't the first
person to question Sandy Hook and I
apologize years ago it's estimated that
Jones and his companies are worth
between 135 and 270 million dollars he
is trying to Shield his assets by
declaring bankruptcy but that's not
always guaranteed to work still analysts
say this could make future conspiracy
theorists think before attacking victims
of horrific crimes again these families
lost young children six and seven years
old six teachers also died that day
Jones wasn't in court but back on the
airwaves using this trial to raise money
not for those he hurt but for himself I
remember I'm in bankruptcy we got two
years of appeals the money you donate is
not go to these people it goes to fight
this fraud and it goes to stabilize the
company they want to shut down that's
why the the the the the analyst Chasers
did this unrepentant still but now
potentially eventually he might pay a
very steep price
Al Jazeera Washington
Stanley is a Yale University philosophy
professor and the author of how
propaganda Works he joins us live from
New Haven in Connecticut thank you for
your time sir your reaction to the
nearly one billion dollars in Damages
put on Jones what does it tell us about
what the jury was thinking
well it's a terribly sad and tragic case
uh it's an open and shot defamation case
legally speaking you're not allowed to
lie I could make obvious lies about
people in a way that damages their
reputation and this is an open and shot
legal case that was decided long ago we
now have the uh the jury's uh decisions
about the liability uh so there's no
issue here uh about uh that that he
violated the law it's not a free speech
case at all uh he violated the law and
and what he did was so horrific that the
the costs he's been he's being asked to
pay are entirely justifiable and
hopefully this will do something to
curtail the kind of massive conspiracy
theorizing uh that is so damaging
democracy you can cannot have wild and
false conspiracies in a democracy
because they undermine the shared
reality that's required for policy
making what's extraordinary is that he
made millions of dollars over the years
falsely describing the shooting as a
hoax and accusing the victims families
of being act as complicit in the plot
how exactly did he do that
well there's money to be made in
destroying reality uh we know this it it
makes people think that that there is no
common reality that that the elites are
lying to you you the way to do it is
take the most uh the most sort of
obvious moving thing in this case Sandy
Hook one of the great tragedies in
American history and say it's all a fake
and a lie and that will really
destabilize people and and it will
confirm their senses it'll give them a
sense of confirmation that their
mistrust in Elites that their mistrust
in the media that their mistrust in
reality is somehow legitimate and so he
used this immense tragedy to uh to uh
not only to victimize the the parents
and and and affect those affected by the
murderous Rampage in Sandy Hook but he
used it to victimize the Americans who
who who he fraud who he he defrauded by
feeding their their sense of Abandonment
and betrayal uh by uh by the system uh
and making it make trying to legitimate
it in this horrific way
you alluded to this Mr Jones is just one
individual in an information landscape
Rife with falsehoods about a range of
things from the covid-19 pandemic to
stolen elections so on and so forth
to what extent will this verdict and at
other verdicts like this quell that
misinformation and the spread of
misinformation
now I don't do prediction I'm not in the
prediction business but I can't explain
why it is vital that it that it does uh
it's a vital that it does quell a quell
this we need it to because the way
democracy works is we all have to have a
shared reality and common reactions to
that shared reality so we can discuss
them together if we can't have common
Rea if we can't agree on the truth and
then have reactions to that truth that
then how can we formulate together
policies about how to deal with reality
uh these conspiracy theorists are
destroying that common reality and
making democracy impossible
Jason Stanley very good to talk to you
from Yale University philosophy
professor and author of several books
including how proper propaganda Works
joining staff from New Haven Connecticut
thank you for your time
thank you